we have to be aware that that mediocrity
always attacks excellence one of the
arts that have been lost in our world is
the art of listening a lot of people are
just run by what others are thinking
about them rather than what their soul
one yeah is it possible to life vision
when you're at the bottom not only is it
possible that's probably the best time
to do it need motivation watch the top
ten we believe nation
he's Michael Bernard man with and here's
my tank on his top Tambor was a success
enjoy people have a tendency to care
more about what other people are
thinking about them than with their soul
wants and so they live from you know
what is someone so gonna think of me and
what's my mother gonna think of me
what's the size society's gonna think of
me and inside everyone has a destiny
bright beautiful destiny the soul is
calling us to greatness your name of
your show you know to be great beings to
be great lights to live fully and
oftentimes people will dim their light
in order to fit into someone else's
paradigm and end up with crisis end up
with disease end up with prolonged
sadness yeah when if you just step out
of that this is all much life to live
you see so I think a lot of people are
just run by what others are thinking
about them rather than with their soul
ones yeah rule number two ask empowering
questions I think about people who have
circumstances that aren't as good as
mine or yours is it possible to life
vision when you're at the bottom not
only is it possible that's probably the
best time to do it when circumstances
and situations are pressing in upon us
the only way we can overcome them is to
go within to actually begin to ask very
empowering questions with the awareness
that this universal presence and its law
will answer any question that you ask so
if you're in a situation that is
pressing on you and you ask what's
trying to emerge in my life
what is my gift to share mmm what is my
purpose why am I here on the planet not
just how can I pay my rent not just how
can I stop the pain which are bad
questions it's not even not just even
what should I do
not even what should i do what should i
do but the universal questions you ask
empowering questions the universe will
answer these questions in a language and
in a way that you can understand they'll
be inter prompting there'll be intuitive
hits
signs symbols dreams it'll come in the
language of their own the individual
soul and heart the difficulty is that
when people are in tough situations they
ask disempowering questions
well they say what's wrong who's to
blame yeah why me yes those are the
disempowering questions so the universe
will answer those two it'll pull on the
database of human experience and say you
were born on the wrong side of the
tracks or you were born on the right
side of the tracks are you this happened
or that happened it will give you a bevy
of excuses but if you ask an empowering
question you'll get an answer to rise
above the muck so it's all about the
question the sincerity of the question
and then the ability and the willingness
to to really listen to really be
available that that's where the juice is
and that is available to every human
being whether an individual's in prison
where their individual is imprisoned by
circumstance imprisoned in their own
mind about an event that happened in
their past it doesn't matter once you
ask with sincerity the universe will
answer that's that's the way it operates
rule number three master the art of
listening now here's the deal as you
begin to ask empowering questions you
begin to active activate the soul
Faculty of hearing
one of the arts that have been lost in
our world is the art of listening
individuals fail to listen and they fail
to comprehend listening is a lost art
you want to bring listening back in your
spiritual practice so in life visioning
as we begin to feel that were surrounded
by a universal presence of divine love
we begin to ask the question what is the
vision for my life what is the universe
seeking to express through me what is
the idea that the universe is trying to
make as my life was trying to emerge and
then we have a moment of pure listening
with our judgment or censorship we just
begin to listen and that which is called
the still small voice we begin to
understand it be after a while becomes
the only voice the chatter in the mind
we no longer hear that we begin to hear
was trying to emerge rule number four
constantly grow and evolve we have to be
aware that that mediocrity always
attacks excellence mmm
you know it's got it's kind of a rule no
one's attacking a couch potato right he
only cares okay there's a view sitting
on the couch eating potato chips and
getting fat and doing nothing no one
says anything but the moment you start
to walk toward your dream and you start
to break habits you start to change
relationships that no longer serve in
that dream you start you start to be
talked about now many people are afraid
of failure which really means that
they're afraid of being ridiculed but
once you become aware that you're going
to be ridicule if you fail and you're
gonna be talked about if you succeed
then you cable to put that aside because
you know you're gonna be talked about it
no matter what yeah you know if you go
for do you fall oh he went forward and
he didn't make it or if you go forward
and succeed they'll say oh it was luck
you know you know whatever they say
about you so once you get out of your
mind or become aware that people are
going to talk about you either way then
you go for it
you see and and at the end of the day
you are different because you went for
it that you going for it
actually brings out latent powers and
gifts and talents within you that can't
come to bloom unless you go for it so
then when you reach your next
mountaintop and mountaintops are endless
yeah when you meet when you reach your
next peak who's with you are the people
that are supposed to be with you or
could be with you based on what you have
become now you go for another peak and
then the people that are supposed to be
with you there or with you and all the
nations they might shed some people who
came with you from the first ballast
yeah some people might come with you to
the next mountain but some people might
be left behind right absolutely you keep
your heart open you never just yeah
jettison people out of your life your
heart is open but you're constantly
growing and unfolding also if you want
daily motivation from writers like
george RR martin JK rowling olive oil
there's checking my 250 for writers
wisdom series the link is in the
description below it's free and you'll
love it
I've been reading a lot of historical
fiction and I've been in a back of my
mind it's not enough to know what you
want you have to to do what you want to
be what you want the knowledge that you
have emerged wiser and stronger from
setbacks means that you are ever after
secure in your ability to survive revive
rise above energy how do you prevent
other people's energy from affecting you
so much I can feel when there's toxic
energy around somebody's angry or
stressed out I take that off absolutely
you become uninterested in it you are
not interested in what other people are
thinking about you you're only
interested in what the universe is
thinking about you and what is the
universe thinking about you that you are
you're a beautiful expression of
infinite possibility and I believe that
you do believe I believe you're just
sensitive to other people so instead of
being interested in their vibration you
begin to impute a vibration that is to
give a vibration so whenever you see
negative energy or feeling negative
energy you're going to share love you
you're gonna give peace from yourself
it's gonna lift your frequency so you
become impervious you you will be be
touched by the lower vibration ruler six
set a worthy goal
some people have goals that they want to
manifest
but the goals have come from the
parental fantasies with their mother
wanted them to be when they grew up
where their dad or what the teacher told
you you should be at what your church
told you you should be no there's
something within you and you want to
have a goal that's worthy of that which
is within you and that grows you at the
same time so as I'm speaking to you
right now and when should you begin to
remember those moments in your life from
the time that you could first think as a
child as an infant there were some ideas
that flow through you there were some
meant to be isms there were some ways
that you wanted to challenge yourself to
make a difference on the planet before
you got bombarded with societal
fantasies there was something about you
because you know what you chose to be
here you're not an accident regardless
of what your parents may have told you
you are an on purpose with a purpose
so as I'm speaking to you you you're
becoming aware you're starting to
remember that being that knew why he or
she arrived on the planet the gifts they
wanted to share and the difference here
it is the difference they wanted to make
on the planet you want to make a
difference on the planet that difference
you want to make is a goal that's worthy
of your soul
so this is what I want you to do I want
you to consider answering this question
what difference do I want to make on the
planet before I leave how do I want the
world to be better before I leave how do
I want my relationships my neighbourhood
anything I encounter to be better before
I leave as you are answering that
question you are beginning to bump into
the reason why you chose this
incarnation rule number seven don't
embrace praise or criticism what's been
the biggest challenge for you as a human
being living a spiritual path over less
you know 30 plus years what's been your
greatest human challenge I think just
just dealing with human beings
we're complicated people I mean it's
it's it's the best and the worst in the
same area I mean you see human beings
that are on the verge of great discovery
you see miracles you see people coming
out of the depths of despair and
depression and illness and sickness and
addiction rising mm-hmm and then you see
human beings who will criticize and
complain and gossip and attack you know
all in the same day he may get the same
deal you may you know and so I've
learned to not embrace either one of the
imposters which is praise or criticism
you know I I don't run towards praise I
don't run from criticism and I just
don't deal in that area you know I just
keep my attention on that which is real
and keep moving forward
choose your vibration we are vibrational
beings you know we're not just flesh and
blood you know if you put anything under
a microscope an intense microscope you
can ultimately see that everything is
vibration and in ask the scientists are
not telling us there's information there
but it's not solid it's always moving so
we're vibrational beings so as you were
just saying when we lift our vibration
to what we want to experience it happens
first on a vibratory level
and then it shows up and manifest in our
life so people who are holding on to
rancor animosity they're slowing down
their vibration just had an aha there
you're actually when you when you
recognize your vibrational frequency
you're drawing into yourself all the
time literally the vibration that is
most like what you're putting out right
correct
right you cannot another way of saying
is you cannot have which you're not
willing to become vibrationally if you
do get it you'll lose it ah this is why
people that win the lottery they lose
everything yeah but they'll finally get
the person they think they obviously
can't keep that can't keep the
relationship or they'll get a modicum of
success but can't hold on to it because
inside they weren't vibrationally
aligned they really hadn't become it so
you can temporarily manipulate and get
things but to have it completely you
have to lift your vibration and become
that in vibration
find your inner greatness there are
things within us that we have no idea
that are even there because we've been
indoctrinated by the society in which we
are living a high tech low touch society
consumerism materialism fear doubt worry
and so we visualize what we think we
want to be happy nothing wrong with that
but beyond that there's a gift a talent
a capacity within us all that's trying
to emerge Robert Browning indicated you
know there's an inner splendor
you know this trying to escape so the
visioning process invites the inner
splendor to come up that may shock our
surface mind you may it may surprise us
as to what's trying to emerge and what
we must become and now outside of our
present paradigm
they're the miraculous is there it's
something trying to happen to us and we
keep growing and and growing
so visualization is a stage of our
spiritual growth it teaches us there's a
law in the universe teaches us the
friendliness of the universe it teaches
us that our thoughts transmute
themselves and the things it teaches us
that things don't just happen they
happen just it's a good teaching stage
but then once we become comfortable and
realize that the universe is friendly we
can begin to give up control and ask a
higher question and now we lose control
we move into surrender that's that's
that's the big game and Rule No Return
the last one before a very special bonus
lift is make music
[Music]
come forward you and
by the spirit as opposed to like this of
divine in reality in that domain as a
spiritual practice
[Music]
activating my stimulus package inherit
now I've got a really special bonus tip
for Michael and how to take baby steps
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point lighting questions time to move
from just watching the video to taking
action in your life for business here we
go question number one what is your next
worthy goal number two what is your
inner greatness and number three where
do you need to do a better job of
listening I am a double lung transplant
recipient it's been over a year now well
my problem is right now is applying my
passion and getting over the fear
getting over everything that causes me
to not um you know continue forward what
are you afraid of Tiffany success the
success scares me I've never envisioned
anything that God is drawing me to yes
so until now until now oh yeah and I
feel like it's kind of beyond my reach
okay so this look at your past successes
so you're breathing yes so that was a
successful operation oh yeah do you
still have life to give you still have
love to share you still have success to
radiate yes yes okay so you're not
afraid of it what you're afraid of is
the future okay so you have somewhere
implanted on the future some anxiety
around success so I need you to stay
right here I want you to feel the
success that you now have experience
with the healing of your body temple and
any other aspects of success in your
life I want you be right here now in
this feeling of success I want you to
begin to see yourself living the life
that you say God is pulling you to live
and then take baby steps walking in that
direction and every single day do at
least one step so once you take baby
steps you'll create spiritual emotional
and soulful movement that will keep
carrying you carrying you have bigger
steps bigger steps bigger steps and
you'll see that you're already in the
success even before it manifests even
before it shows up you're already in the
field
of it and then when it shows up it's
like oh I knew this all along I was
already feeling it yeah
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on the Dalai Lama the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
son says I'm the good person some say
bad person that doesn't matter some of
my own motivation for thinking